[Music]  targeting folks for money officials have  put out numerous scam warnings about  criminals calling or emailing seniors  offering fake vaccine appointments  they've even spotted social media ads  offering to sell  shots the scammers take the money and  never deliver  even those who've received the shot  legitimately need to be cautious the  better business bureau says people  posting their vaccination cards  online putting themselves at risk the  problem is those vaccine cards have a  lot of private information on it it has  your birth date on it you can sometimes  have  your home address on it clearly the full  spelling of your name  well that's a scammer's paradise experts  say it's safer just share a picture of  the vaccination sticker  instead and they also stress the vaccine  is free